i maintain that walter hamada is unfit
for positional leadership
and i am willing at any point to submit
to a polygraph test
wow jeez
homie damn
oh oh let's see it it's going to happen
now do it
live streaming polygraph on instagram
wow
well guys this is certainly going to
make the snyder cut
interesting to watch this here um
got a piece of news here about ray
fisher nothing else happened in the
world today
nothing else happened in the world no
news no news at all
this is the only news shows
no one's talking about anything
[Music]
okay so ray fisher put out a statement
and here we go i have received official
confirmation that warner brothers
pictures
has decided to remove me from the cast
of the flash
okay there we go i mean we i feel like
we
a lot of us predicted that that would
probably be the case based off of the
situation we just talked about in a
video i think
last week i strongly disagree with their
decision but it is one that is
unsurprising this is literally the first
time i'm i'm reading this personally i
know you've read it i haven't read it
yet yeah
um despite the misconception cyborg's
involvement in the flash
wow
wow okay
because someone put out forget which
scooper said like oh no that was just a
rumor oh
wow [ __ ] yeah cyborg's involvement in
the flash
was much larger than a cameo and while i
do mourn the lost
opportunity to bring victor stone back
to the screen bringing awareness to the
actions of walter
hamada will prove to be much more
important contribution to our world
damn this is a whole can of worms on
december 30th 2020 i made it clear
that i cannot with a clear conscience
participate in any
production associated with the current
president dc films walter hamada
okay the reasoning behind that
declaration was twofold
walter's purposeful attempt to undermine
the justice league investigation in
order to protect his friend and
former co-president jeff johns walter's
attempt to protect himself by
contributing to the public dissemination
of lies and misinformation
about myself and the justice league
investigation and warner brothers
pictures september 4th statement
to the rap okay okay
so i mean it sounds like he was
fired but either way he wasn't going to
go through with it
this is the impression that i'm getting
unless walter hermata is somehow
magically removed from all this yeah
yeah because he's saying that uh he was
removed from the cast
meaning i was fired but regardless he
made it pretty clear that if with walter
hamada he wouldn't be involved anyway
yeah
damn yeah i mean the the big part is
like the clarification that he was
supposed to have a much larger role in
there absolutely
that flash movie just keeps getting
reworked doesn't it
yeah so fascinated to know what we're
actually going to see if we'll ever
actually
see it bear in mind walter hamada
interfering with the justice league
investigation is a completely separate
issue than the investigation itself
and walter's behavior was not a point of
focus for the investigation of the
justice league reshoots
his dangerous and enabling actions
during the investigation process
must be called to account man he's going
to war he's going hard
i mean we already know he's been but i
can imagine just how much
more fired up the guy is now on july 7
2020 during a 57 minute long phone call
walter i made multiple attempts to have
him escalate my claims and misconduct
against
whedon johns and john berg through the
proper channels
and and that happened rather than
escalate the situation when initially
asked
walter disparage joss whedon and john
berg and attempt to cover for jeff johns
when i altered walt alerted walter
that jeff was in fact a major
contributor to the issues experience
including blatant racism
i can imagine it's hard to find real
proof on these kind of things if you
know if all this is to be believed yeah
because there's some people who just
really don't believe him anymore and and
there are some people who are
who just who do champion and believe him
walter
right now i might upon like i could
believe it
but i can't really say just yet
yeah but at the same time like i said
you guys like this really hard to find
proof
walter tried because a lot of this
sounds like it's conversational stuff
well it's not like they're sending him
text messages you know
yeah so that's why that's probably what
drives every
victim of any of this treatment bananas
is because yeah so much of the time it's
a hearsay situation of this person said
this to me
well was there someone around the video
exactly exactly yeah that's it walter
tried but to
no avail to get me to reveal the names
of witnesses and other specifics that we
could use to forewarn
jeff of the claims being brought against
him
okay so he had witnesses but he didn't
bring them
okay i mean there's so much like you
just talked about a 57-minute phone call
sorry there's a two-page statement so
there's so much more to this than
what's here walter even went so far as
to sharply dismiss certain claims of
mine as untrue because of his work
experience and personal relationship
with jeff all right you gotta have
you gotta have proof that's the that's
the tough part man that's the tough part
is like you
gotta have the real like especially with
stuff like this
but i mean maybe if walter hamada was so
flippant
in in the manner of like nope don't
believe it
i mean you need that's what you're going
up against though and you need to have
but why wouldn't he provide the names of
witnesses that's the kind of the curious
part that's what i'm chewing on yeah i
mean maybe he thought that
he would just go above raf i mean he is
above ray fisher in the hierarchy of
warner brothers so maybe he would go and
retire or
fix it up or something or yeah just warn
jeff johns but at the same time if
walter hermata
is the president as the guy you're
directly dealing with you'd think that
everything would need to be on the table
so i am a little
confused by that especially something
like this watson nikea that he was
briefed on joss whedon's problematic
behavior
well in advance of my speaking out on
july 1st 2020.
okay he indicated doesn't mean he said
for sure that's like an assumption
essentially
that briefing likely came from jeff
johns with whom walter served as
co-president dc films
regardless of how he was made aware
walter knew there was legitimacy to my
claims against joss whedon
yet he persisted in trying to minimize
and dismiss the situation claiming that
it is a producer's
job to protect the director and that he
was looking to move beyond
anything to do with zack snyder's
justice league
fascinating i mean walter hamada has i
forget exactly
what that quote was we brought it up in
last week's video oh the cul-de-sac
thing about yeah it's a dead end it's a
dead end
you just stop there
i mean yeah i don't know
literally this is something where you
people are choosing
sides strongly and it's like well which
one do you just more believe
it once i argued walter down that he
agreed to escalate my claims as
asks citing it as above his pay grade
really
no intention of backing down walter made
matters worse by making
a tastelessly self-aware joke about not
wanting me to put him
on twitter about this well here we are
oh
well now you oh wow yeah
he's bringing it all here on every
social platform
damn dude um we need receipts or
something
ah despite walter's best efforts the
justice league investigation was able to
expose the racist
coerce cobra i'll get there
behavior of jeff johns during his tenure
with warner media's affiliates
okay the joke affleck also led to more
media party no ways between warren media
and joss whedon
well maybe legally and financially
safe for me while it beat while it be
may
he had a typo wow wow ray ray this is a
legal case
maybe legally and financially safer to
quietly phase jeff john's out or to let
joss whedon exit of his own accord
i sure neither are responsibilities my
responsibilities are and have been
to try to protect those that were brave
enough to lend their voice to the
justice league investigation
to use with little power i position but
who lent their
i want to know who those witnesses are
yeah i need to know i deserve everything
to be in on this investment yeah
to use what little power i possess to
ensure that the workplace behavior
exhibited during the justice league
reshoots and its
investigation never happens again
no one in any profession should have to
argue with their employer for the claims
of abuse racism and discrimination to be
taken to the proper chain of command
and when you're making strong
accusations though i think there
is the side that but stuff like this you
gotta but then he's saying he presented
some stuff we just don't know exactly
what what that is and that's something
according to this he's saying some
people did speak and but there were some
who he didn't give up names to
okay and no one in any position of
leadership
should attempt to dissuade those wishing
to report such claims from doing so
i agree that it should be fully it
should be if this accusation is being
brought up it should be taken seriously
i agree with that
walter's accusations have transformed
this narrative from an investigation of
onset misconduct in 2017
to the examination of the present-day
cover-up culture of hollywood
his contribution to warner brothers
pictures september 4th
through the rap was false cowardly and
reckless i maintained that walter hamada
is unfit for position of leadership
and i am willing at any point to submit
to a polygraph test
wow jeez
homie damn
oh oh let's see it it's going to happen
now do it
live streaming podcast
live streaming holy crap that's crazy
go live with walter i mean damn dude
i've been talking all about receipts you
get to this point you're like
let's get that polygraph going do a
wired polygraph
[Music]
i don't know how many instances of
workplace abuse walter has attempted to
cover in the past but hopefully the
justice league investigation will be the
last
and at the end of my time at cyborg
there's a cost for helping to bring
awareness accountability to walter
hamada's actions i'll pay it gladly
onward accountability over entertainment
ray fisher you reach a point in life
where you simply must take a stand
well damn i mean i
think we all know we got to get that
polygraph going
yeah and then during the polygraph we
need to split
to ask details on what that flash
appearance was at the same time
i mean think about it though like he
could do a polygraph
let's say he asks the question they
asked the question all these like you
know
damning questions he passes the
polygraph of flying colors
and then bam people will come out and be
like well here's why polygraphs aren't
reliable
raise an actor you know yeah exactly
he's really good at staying calm
at the end of the day it's like the the
position he's in
really relies on
on on solid proof to take against him
because he's going up against people in
much more powerful positions than him
absolutely and like i'm saying
like i it's not that i don't believe him
and it's not that i
i don't in the beginning
i was initially like ray fisher's side
right away
and i'm likely to believe him that's the
thing is i'm very much more likely to
to believe him at this and but also come
from the side of
it's really hard to provide proof and i
know that when we're talking about a
legal battle
everything rides on proof everything
rides on evidence you know
yeah and the thing is that's the hardest
thing to find so if i were to talk
one-on-one with this guy be like i
believe you dude
but you don't have proof so you won't
win like well yeah
especially in cases of you know
interpersonal misconduct
it's so hard to prove or to get support
and i've you know i mean you can see
because then other people put in their
careers on the line and now
it would be even harder for people to to
fight with him
yeah like absolutely damn that is crazy
this is
that's a bummer yeah that's a bummer for
him um
but he seems dead set on
like i just don't the reason i believe
him is because of like well why would a
guy put his whole career
this was everyone knew this was the
point that he was putting his career on
the line by doing this absolutely from
the very beginning he was putting his
career on the line
and every time he shows back up he's
doubling down exactly exactly he's
always putting his career on the line
and for someone to be this outspoken
about it
because some people i've seen other
people online on youtube
who who are who just call him like no
this is he just did this
in the wake of like the black lives
matter movement that was like the
main thing i've heard he did this in the
wake of the black lives matter movement
to garner attention and sympathy
for stuff that probably wasn't even that
bad that stuff that he's being
accusatory of
happens on set all the time that that's
the main main
flip side of those against ray fisher
but
because again every time you think
they've
clapped back in some kind of effective
way he just keeps coming
back that's what i mean it's not yeah
that's that's uh
i i can't i can't believe it's just that
that's ridiculous to me well yeah and
the main question that leaves me with is
just how much
is how much of these things that are
withheld because like this has become
such a public thing and that's a
troublesome thing to me because there's
certain details i'm sure legally
we're just not allowed to hear of course
i'm sure this statement
is even omitting specifics we're not
allowed to talk about one 57-minute
phone call yeah and i'm like damn
like come on um well
i mean i i want to i want to stay
updated on what ray fisher's fight is
and you know like we could recover this
from time to time it's not
this is something that is of genuine
interest it's an important thing to talk
about
yeah and i mean it is i mean this is a
big machine and with
people like harvey weinstein we've
learned there's tons and tons and tons
of cover-up culture within
hollywood and pretty much any business
where humans congregate
and then the fan uproar can be even
crazier yeah
once we get to the point of the snyder
cup coming out
and with as much as zack snyder has to i
mean let's face it snyder cute fans
are probably the most passionate side of
the dc
films more than any other side of the dc
films so if freaking cyborg is the heart
of the film and he is like one of the
main highlights is the standout he's
great
whoa you're going to hear an uproar i
mean it's already happening
from the steiner cut camp yeah and um
and i mean this will definitely taint
any like plans moving forward
for that you know even if you don't want
to hold on to the culture oh
dude this is this is nuts this is big
yeah
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
man do you stand with ray fisher would
you rather just wait till evidence it's
like that's where i'm at
i'm like look at the moment i'm likely
to believe ray fisher
at the same time i'm like there's a
legal battle and i know that you can't
win unless
you have some evidence yeah that's the
thing that's that's kind of where i'm at
you know
um but damn [ __ ] let's let's see what's
let's hope it works out for the best
yeah whatever that means